hey hey was wir heute ich habe jetzt
gerade die haare gemacht weil ich hatte
eben und jetzt habe ich meine haare von
interessant und gutes video ja es ist
ganz angenehm
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video jahre hatte ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut mir auch
danke ich muss mich ein bisschen beeilen
wir haben heute wieder einen gast im
video und zwar dem pascal was galt
nämlich bei instagram geschrieben joecks
ich schaue gerne deine videos vielleicht
hast du ja mal lust mitzumachen oder mit
mir ein video zu drehen ich kann mir
auch gerne fragen beantworten
irgendwie so weil fast kalt ist leider
blind oder erblindet ich glaube er war
nicht sein ganzes leben lang sind und
ich habe gedacht da ich momentan ja eh
die hoch lade jeden tag um 19 uhr
schreibt solche investoren habe ich fast
keinen nachteilen eingeladen da kommt
jetzt gleich im hauptbahnhof an
ich hole ihn da ab und wir verbringen
einen spannenden tag zusammen drehen
vielleicht das ein oder andere video ich
bin echt mal gespannt wie pascal drauf
ist und wie er sein leben führt ich
nehme euch mitmachen kleinen block und
wir müssen uns jetzt echt geil weil ich
muss ihnen gleich abholen und ich habe
noch 25 minuten also los geht's ans klar
leute ich bin jetzt hier angekommen am
hauptbahnhof ja da ist der hauptbahnhof
und da muss ich jetzt auf jeden fall
muss ich da jetzt zu gleis 9
er kommt der pascal an und dann bin ich
mal auf den tag gespannt ich habe keinen
plan was die so machen ihr habt nichts
geplant muss ja schon sagen hier ist
immer so also dann suchen wir mal 1991
scharfstellen kann man da bitte jetzt
was sie einmal ganz herumrennen
ist das denn für mini gleis da kommt ein
zug
was sind denn erst mal finden
ich habe ihn gefunden
hey hey was höchstens noch nicht alles
gut was auch anschlüsse auf der
durchgezogenen linie
die daten machen
ich habe das gar nicht abgeholt wir
haben es gerade schon ein bisschen
connected was geht ab du kannst ja mal
kurz vorstellen oder so johann ich bin
der pascal kommen jetzt aus münster oder
spinnen hin studien münster und bin
heute nach einem alex und erzähler spiel
ein bisschen was später genau ja cool
also gefordert erst mal zu mir habe ich
gedacht ich weiß ich kann mir später
noch entspannt was essen gehen und dann
gucken wir mal was wir noch zu machen
ich habe noch eine coole idee gehabt
sehe ich hier gleich mal hatte ich nicht
mal und wir fangen jetzt erst mal los
ist was gesagt 18 uhr 20
ja wenn du wohl erst merken und das
kostet der pass galt schon gehört mein
auto erkannt was schon mein köln
jaja praktikum können gemacht wir sind
jetzt zu mir gefahren und gehen das erst
mal die wohnung soll ist eigentlich
immer so construction bank betreute hier
direkt hier links gucken oder weil es
ist ein reger ich finde es aber gut wenn
man haben wir nicht so viel nicht
durchgehend augenkontakt halten muss mit
den leuten besser so ein bisschen in die
kamera gucken und so dass ich also ich
sag dir dann immer vor die kamera stellt
so leid ich habe jetzt gerade die haare
gemacht weil ich hatte eben
und jetzt habe ich meine haare also wir
sind jetzt auf jeden fall bei mir in der
wohnung und wir gehen das erst mal kurz
einkaufen weil ich habe keine getränke
reich kann jetzt nicht zu trinken
anbieten leider ich wollte ich nur
gefangen du kannst ja mal kurz den
leuten erzählen seit wann meine videos
oder weil das münster geschrieben so hey
hast du nicht mehr bock irgendwie sowie
den wir zu machen dem alex seine videos
gucke ich jetzt so seiten dreiviertel
jahr ja so angefangen habe zu gucken und
ich habe mir gedacht ich sehen hier
nicht dann ist nicht so schlimm aber ich
hab halt immer so ein bisschen
eigentlich von belanglos videos zu
gucken hier angezeigt werden
einer hat auch der begriff und ich fand
immer ganz nice man büssten abend
entspannt was zu schauen und du machst
das ganz gut danke du hast mir schon
jetzt erklärt glaube ich dass du bei
deinem macbook oder so so das halt alles
direkt lesen kannst was da oder wie die
videos heißen sondern weil ich so ein
extra programm dafür oder wie ja also
mein macbook ist momentan kaputt und ich
habe mein iphone
und das liest mir alles vor wo ich drauf
klicken und dann entsprechend
vergleichen vielleicht zeigen also
videos oder was labert mir letztendlich
vorwurf drauf drückt aber da und mach
mal irgendwann mal ein video von mir
angeht das werk von interessant also
damit auch immer versteht das system
langsam wird sodann kann ich drauf pico
dann bei werbung voll cool ja danke also
damit habe ich noch nicht aber das muss
man ja auch lernen müssen oder nicht ja
klar als am anfang muss man halt die
stimme ganz langsam stellen waren dann
ist es denn überhaupt nicht gewöhnt so
aber so wenn man sich so nach und nach
die grünen damit immer schneller immer
schneller so wie man sie stellt also wir
gehen jetzt erst mal einkaufen was dein
lieblingsgetränk
keine ahnung stricken ist alles okay
jetzt vom fitness machen also oder was
ist dein fail sports so den
kraftsportler recht man sieht nicht
einmal gut also schon ein bisschen was
es eben kann dann würdest du sagen wenn
sich zivilisten
was kannst du heben maximal 225 kilo vom
boden auf
so wir sind jetzt hier bei den getränken
irgendein wunsch erwartet man ja ja red
bull gibt es hier sogar gekühlt heute
jedoch nicht hier hatte hier also im
sommer ist unten rechts sommer beatrice
in blau oder das weiße nehmt einfach
beide nehmen wir noch ein einzel mit dem
wasser halten mussten noch einmal hier
abgesehen vom einkaufen zurück haben
sind jetzt hier in seinem zimmer ein
bisschen bequem gemacht haben branchen
darüber gesprochen ich wollte ich das
jetzt noch fragen damit die leute ist
oder meine berlin stellt sich
wahrscheinlich auch die frage wenn du es
sagst ich brauche das und das aus dem
supermarkt wie machst du das
also da gibt es ja bestimmt irgendwelche
möglichkeiten fördern ja also es hat
ganz unterschiedlich hatte ich hier mal
kurz auf die andere seite gewechselt
also eigentlich recht interessant ja es
ist ganz unterschiedlich
das kommt darauf an so jetzt ist es aus
meiner heimat also marktkenntnis halt so
zum beispiel da kommt man also im
supermarkt in einkaufszentren oder sowas
sonst mal lustig oder an die kasse
gegangen hatte gesagt er aber jemand
dann hilft oder so und das ist ein
problem
ja es hat einfach gewusst wo soma toast
brot oder milch oder sowas steht jetzt
zum beispiel das ist halt so dass ich in
supermärkten hat gelernt habt oder
auswendig so in einem so weiß wo halt
alles genau steht und dann kann ich auch
mit mandy oder so nem also ein qr code
scannen oder werner ich kann ja mal mein
tagesablauf erzählen ich stehe morgens
aufgeht ein bild zur uni oder wenn es
keine uni abscheulich meistens ein video
fleischer gerade daily videos hoch
kriegst das mit und jedes guckst du
wahrscheinlich auch oder hatte gerade
eine gute idee
und zwar eigentlich hatte ich eine idee
dass wir sonne gehört challenge machen
weil dein gehör ist er extrem gut
trainiert
und was wären aber lasst uns mal einfach
gegeneinander was essen ich verbinde mir
die augen weil dann sehe ich ja auch
nichts und dann schauen wir wie die
täler danach aussehen weil er meinte
dass er sehr sauber essen kann und ich
kann mir vorstellen wenn ich nichts sehe
dabei das meint heller danach absolut
katastrophe aussieht das blöde ist ja
gab es bei dir in münster auf den lippen
kannst du das weil die liebe zum
beispiel hat geklappt also die gibt es
nicht mehr
ja vor schade weil ich habe immer bei
denen bestellten okay wir haben uns
jetzt ganz klassisch auf eine margarita
geeinigt die werden wir uns teilen dann
hat das geil noch das baguette carbonara
ich habe spaghetti napoli dann noch
zweimal tiramisu als nachtisch das heißt
wir haben eigentlich ein ziemlich großes
menü wir brauchen noch was zu trinken
oder das haben jetzt bestellen für die
essens challenge sie kommt dann
irgendwie die tage online und war es ja
auch gesagt dass du einen eigenen
youtube-channel hast ne oder hattest du
musik gemacht hast ja ich hatte immer
vor sieben acht jahren oder so also
schon ewig her ich mal so ein bisschen
musik gemacht und das auf youtube
hochgeladen aber so laut ich habe gerade
schon mal unser setup aufgebaut weil wir
gleich diese essen zu machen wollen
also das für jeder was essen und dann
gucken wir mal so ich es auch und
verbundenen augen gucken wir mal wieder
nach die teller aussehen aber ist ja
auch egal ich wollte es nur kosten
das hier nutzen weil wir haben den
leuten auch ich glaube da interessieren
sich viele für wir haben ja gerade schon
mal intensiv darüber gesprochen also du
konntest du früherer sehen genau dass du
vielleicht das noch mal ganz kurz und
knapp erklärt wie das sich bei dir so
entwickelt hat nokia also bei mir war es
hat so also ich bin jetzt komplett blind
aber das war ich schon immer sondern ich
habe ein frühlings tritt gesehen also
auf dem rechten auge seitdem ich hier
bin nichts mehr und auf dem linken auge
wo das total schlecht seitdem ich so
zehn fw bin oder so mit 13 14 war es
dann gar nichts mehr sodass wird dann
langsam noch schlechter ja das ist bei
mir alles so krankheitsbedingt so kommt
halt auch nicht so viel machen oder
nicht mehr als gemacht wurde
sodann mit 10 11 habe ich sagen alles
angefangen so zu lernen so will
eigentlich zum weißen blindenstock oder
diesmal punkt trifft oder wie findet man
sich so zurecht wenn man halt nicht mehr
alles sieht so weit dann aber du nimmst
das ja eigentlich also das ist ja vorher
schon vorlag
und ja also ich finde dass also du bist
sehr sehr aufgeschlossen und drehe das
viel drüber so also es ist eigentlich
cool weil er das hätte ich jetzt selber
auch nicht so gedacht aber irgendwie
dann sagst du dir viel reden kann ich
immer viel aber das ist einfach so dass
man es einfach ganz entspannt macht und
dafür kannst du mir letzten und was du
meinst du was deutscher meister in
deiner kraft sport geworden ist also ja
es macht halt hobbymäßig kraftsport also
kraftdreikampf und habe damals auch
schon wettkämpfe gemacht und so macht
total spaß und ja da ist auch mit
behinderungen keine problematik so und
deswegen mache das seit 56 jahren total
die anderen systemen habe ich einen
deutschen rekord im kreuzheben
aufgestellt
[Musik]
hey leute heute mache ich jetzt mal
meinen eigenen blog oder ich probiere
mal selber aus bis zu filmen kann im
alexander kamera wir haben ein
essentielles gemacht wo und ja jetzt
haben wir's mal hingesetzt zum kaffee zu
trinken und wollte mal schauen wie das
sie mit der kamera läuft und was würdest
du sagen alex alles gut also man sich
auf jeden fall
du bist ganz drauf und wieder mal selber
so was machen soll das ist das
wichtigste
ja das stimmt wir haben auf jeden fall
ein cooles video gedreht das kommt dann
morgen online oder übermorgen ich weiß
noch nicht genau was wir zusagen kommt
es online
okay da machen was übermorgen
wir fahren jetzt zurück zum bahnhof weil
ich jetzt wieder zum bahnhof bringen
wir sind gerade hier musik hören im auto
und er sagte so wenn wir einfach
[Musik]
damals stieß sein konnten sie doch ein
gutes wiederer
es ist ganz angenehm ich habe auch so
freunde die haben mich mal solo musik
das ist für mich dann schon zu laut so
das geht jetzt noch klar
aber du hast ja gerade schon gesagt also
du kannst ja gar noch mal sagen weil es
ja schon war einmal ganz entspannt hat
ja wir haben schon gesagt wenn du mir
mal coole ideen in den kommentaren oder
sowas kommt dass man vielleicht noch mal
irgendwas machen könnte ja genau also
wenn ihr gegner idee habt so mancher
irgendwie sowas schreibt es super gerne
in die kommentare
das jahr
den sound vom auto kann sich noch einmal
zu
sobald man die kamera immer
[Musik]
ja
also als erstwagen kann man das auf
jeden fall gelten
ich warte auf jeden fall noch nicht er
kommt wie gesagt schon mal hier
die oder fuhren dann wird die klage
[Musik]
das war's jetzt ab sagt heute ich muss
sagen also das video ist jetzt schon
fertig ich finde es ist ganz interessant
geworden es war für mich auf jeden fall
auch ein richtig guter tag
eine richtig gute erfahrung und ich habe
einiges dazugelernt wenn ihr sagt mach
doch noch mal videos mit pascal gibt man
dann nach oben und schaut euch gern mal
sein instagram account an ist in der
video beschreibung verlinkt aber nicht
den kanal lockt aktivieren wir sehen uns
morgen um 19 uhr wieder und übermorgen
um 19 uhr gibt es ja dann auch die
ersten szenen die echt lustig geworden
schaut euch das dann auf jeden fall an
haut rein